c'est peut-être sur la pelouse du stade
louis achille que tout commence pour ces
jeunes footballeurs en herbe à travers
leur maîtrise des fondamentaux de la
discipline ils vont tenter de se
distinguer face aux yeux experts des
recruteurs du club professionnel du rc
lens évoluant en ligue 1 cette saison
une opportunité extrêmement rare mise en
place grâce à une collaboration entre
une société de communication spécialisée
dans le sport et la ligue de football de
la martinique créer une passerelle entre
les crêpes professionnels et les clubs
locaux les structures professionnelles à
part professionnalisantes du moins en
guadeloupe et en martinique
et pourquoi pas ensuite une fois que la
destruction et fait proposer à ce que
certains jeunes puissent partir à
l'essai directement dans les centres de
formation que de ces grands clubs
professionnels français dans les
tribunes ils sont deux à juger des
qualités physiques tactiques mais aussi
mental des joueurs de la section
d'excellence du football martiniquais
des critères fondamentaux pour espérer
débuter dans les meilleures conditions
une carrière professionnelle jonché
d'obstacles
mais déjà il viendrait faire un essai au
rc lens parce qu'il faut savoir
s'adapter aussi aux conditions
météorologiques parce que aujourd'hui il
fait 32 en martinique mais à l'heure où
je vous parle il fait 0 degré le rc lens
faut venir s'entraîner aussi avec des
joueurs d'une très bonne qualité et voir
comment ça se passe et après s'il ya une
signature il ya le joueur martiniquais
ne peut pas arriver avant la catégorie
2016 en france la visite de grands clubs
professionnels c'est aussi un excellent
baromètre pour la filière de formation
du football martiniquais
c'est aussi une manière pour les garçons
aussi de savoir à quel point ils sont
mises ensemble puisque les skins ou
lorsqu'on va faire leur tour avec le
recruteur ils sont rangés ou quoi
continuer à bosser et nous aussi coach
ça nous permet d'avoir un curseur pour
pouvoir continuer à travailler à l'issue
de cette séance d'entraînement toute
particulière deux joueurs ont été
repérés pour un éventuel essai au centre
de formation lensois que les autres se
rassurent une nouvelle session est
prévue dans le courant de l'année 2022
nathan